it'll be nestor cortez getting the spot
start assignment on the mound for the
yankees 26 year old will make just his
eighth
starting assignment of his career
after reign in the area for much of the
last 72 hours
and cortez starts it with a strikeout
tonight
and still the numbers just scream at you
though right a 222 average soft liner
gobbled up
by rook noodle door
and this is a good time to get your team
back they've been
led by this great starting pitching
alonzo with a big home run in game one
nestor cortez with an all-business start
to game two as he gets through the mets
in order underway scoreless in the bronx
on the mount for the mets 27 year old
right-hander making just his 14th career
starting assignment it is corey oswalt
dj lemay hugh doing what he does best
going into the opposite field
there to cut it off quickly is pilar
and le mayhew satisfied with the leadoff
single
kind of a different standard here with
the yankees
judge with a tapper out to shortstop
lindor shovels to peraza relay back to
first is not in time
sanchez sends a ball out to center field
plenty of hang time for brandon nimmo
and now number two
[Applause]
sharply hit the shortstop lindor turns
that into a routine out nothing in the
yankee half of the first on to inning
number two
no score in the bronx
seventh pitch of the at-bat on its way
to kevin pallar here two out runner
aboard scoreless tie early on top half
of ending number two
and pallar lines to left
and duhar's got it
one out single left stranded to the
bottom of the second scoreless
yeah matt i mean something that you know
you can speak for hours
and as we speak luke floyd puts a charge
in one and sends it out to left center
field void on his way into second base
with a stand-up double
uh in the bases oh look at rude no door
trying to beat the shift and doing so
brilliantly
it didn't take long
a bunch single on the first pitch first
and third with nobody out and i love
this maddie this is exactly what they
have not been doing
is passing the baton is playing little
baseball the home run will come but this
is playing baseball old school baseball
this is evergreen this would never go
out of style
forced the mets to make plays and i love
this right here joe torre used to always
say
think small and big things will happen
that's exactly what happened there for
the new york yankees they're set up so
runners at first and third nobody out
and it's muscle up time now for corey
oswald as george shella playing
shortstop and the nightcap will be the
batter
well hit to the opposite field chasing
pilar taking a look and that one's gone
a classic yankee stadium homer
three-nothing for the home side nestor
cortez jr he's into his third inning of
work he's allowed just one hit so far
it's been a while since we've seen
jonathan vr pitch cut out of mist now
cortes
strikes out vr that's nestor's third
strikeout oh two strike three fourth
strikeout for cortes you know we thought
well maybe he'll pitch three innings
well i don't think anymore i think he'll
pitch more nice four there's two outs in
the third inning yeah and 41 pitches i i
think he's terrific you know how we feel
about him swung on and line to second
soft line drive and cortez has another
one two three he's been superb one out
nobody on is gary sanchez bets swinging
a miss strike three a breaking ball in
the dirt corey oswalt gets his second
strike out of the game
sanchez down on strikes two up two down
in the third swinging a missed strike
three good inning for corey oswald he
goes through judge sanchez and stanton
one two three nestor cortez why not a
fourth inning tonight he's been fun to
watch
one hit so far though against cortez is
dominic smith stands in that's lined
toward right that's gonna get down a
fair ball base hit as it bounces to the
wall in right field judge gets it in
quickly he's got a strong arm good throw
but not in time dominic smith dives head
first and has a one out double here in
the fourth boon is coming out of the
yankee dugout and with alonzo do up
aaron boone doesn't want to see this one
get away from his left hander so the
righty the side armor darren o'day is
going to enter to face pete pete alonso
had a huge home run i think game one of
the doubleheader lonzo it's a high fly
ball deep to right judges back for it
he's looking up it's gone home run pete
alonso alonzo has homered in each end of
the double header and it is now a three
to two yankee league back to back walks
darren o'day has been ineffective so far
coming out of the bullpen evan pillar
stands any line to left his last time
who rolls one to third le mayhew 2-0
door
and the relay to first is mishandled by
voight as mccann is now at third base
representing the tying run and the
batter will be jonathan vr the 3-2
got him swinging
chad green the new yankee pitcher who is
yes working in both ends of the
doubleheader however he is plenty rested
prior to two pitches in game one he
hadn't worked since june 28th and the
breaking ball stride three outside
corner one man away and brandon nimmo
coming up
back-to-back strikeouts for chad greene
in the fifth the yankees have brett
gardner at second dj lameo at first one
out and aaron judge coming up and that's
bounced a fair ball played by alonso who
stayed on it and that ball just stayed
fair gardner now goes to third la mayu
to second and gary sanchez who's over
two coming up what brett gardner should
be aware is a slider to dirt may get a
cheap run here for the yankees he does
pitch one wild and here comes gardner to
score wow
nice call karnak they have a 4-2 lead
chad green's made it look easy too so
far he's retired all six batters that he
has faced he's pitching into a third
inning here trying to wrap this one up
for the yankees and a call strike three
green gets conforto on three pitches now
struck out four and retired all seven
batters that he's faced cut out of this
breaking ball another strikeout for
green who has been perfect not good
you've been perfect and the mets down to
their last hour struck her not swinging
ball game over yankees win
yankees
win
and boy
do they need that win